what do you know about las vegas
like uh
i've uh
las vegas a really good organization and
uh how i said i'm looking forward to
keep working with them
when did you come to north america
when did you come to north america
oh just last year i played in ohl yeah
and how did you adjust to the game
i like it a lot
i think biggest different is uh
the north american hockey style is more
with back and uh
like it's smaller ring everything's
faster more skilled
i like it a lot if you look at the nhl
and you see certain players who do you
think you're kind of like
i like to watch mikko or antanan in
playoff i think i can
i can take something from his game and
from czech guys i think uh
i'm kind of thomas hurto
hurdle yeah
what would you say is the strongest part
of your game right now oh i think my
hockey sense and
i think
two-way center and i can play every role
i think i'm good in
offensive side and defensive side to
my penalty kill power
you're a big guy aren't you guys
on the ice yeah i tried
what
i guess what part of your game do you
hope to grow the most over the next
couple years
my skating i focused my skating because
i know i need to improve it a lot to
make another step
to be an hl player
i'm guessing you've never been to los
angeles no are you excited yeah a lot
what are you most excited about the city
maybe not the team but the city itself
i don't know i'm excited for another
state nevada and another
another
city just met everything what's it like
when you hear your name
it's
unbelievable feeling it's actually
i was so proud of me and so happy and
i just hugged my parents and
everybody everything was nice what did
your parents say to you ah just
a good life we are proud of you
what did you say to them
thank you
thank you however exciting to meet kelly
mckerman and everyone at the table a lot
of names really fast yeah how many names
do you remember
actually not not enough
remember that one mccrimmon that's a
good one to remember
it's nice and
i'm i'm really happy for them with
some guys i know and
with some guys we're actually great
friends
i'm a good friend with yuri college
yeah i think it's finally after a long
year's first round
for ch for checking yeah
what do you think of it yeah
i like it
it's great